IN THIS ARENA, STAN.
BARCLAY CENTER, I MEAN, JUST
BOSTON HAS TAKEN THE WIND AND
THE SPIRIT AWAY FROM THE NETS
AND THEIR FANS.
THIS WAS A SEASON THAT HAD SO
MUCH PROMISE.
ONE OF THE PRESEASON FAVORITES
TO START THE YEAR, THE BROOKLYN
NETS.
IT ALL FELL APART AT MULTIPLE
TIMES DURING THE SEASON.
>> Stan: LOOK.
THEY SIGN DURANT AND IRVING IN
2019 AND THOUGHT THINGS WOULD BE
DIFFERENT BUT A FIRST ROUND
LOSS.
>> Brian: AND A SWEEP.
BOSTON FOUR IN A ROW AFTER THEY
LOST IN FIVE TO THE NETS LAST
YEAR, THEY ANSWER BACK WITH
THEIR EIGHTH SERIES SWEEP IN
FRANCHISE HISTORY.
LAST DONE IN THE BUBBLE AGAINST
THE SIXERS.
KYRIE IRVING, KEVIN CURRENT HEAD
INTO THE OFF-SEASON.
NOT A SINGLE GAME DECIDED BY
MORE THAN SEVEN POINTS.
BUT ALL FOUR BELONG TO THE
BOSTON CELTICS.
NOW THEY WILL AWAIT THE WINNER
OF THE MILWAUKEE/CHICAGO SERIES.
STAN AND I ARE HEADED TO
MILWAUKEE.
WE WILL HAVE GAME FIVE BETWEEN
THE BUCKS AND THE BULLS ON
WEDNESDAY.
COMING UP, GAME FIVE, JAZZ AND
MAVERICKS.
FOR STAN VAN GUNDY AND STEPHANIE
READY, THE